okay this was gonna be really quick I
didn't have time to set up the whole
thing it's just been officially
announced that Marvel's agents of shield
has been renewed for a second season
plus we're gonna get a limited series of
agent Carter as well which may or may
not tie in directly with agents of
shield we'll see how much that is and
the fact that I'm not convinced that
they're gonna tie in too much directly
sort of gets to a big part of why I
haven't talked too much about ageism
shield I've been watching it I haven't
seen the latest episode that aired but
sort of my issue with the thing is that
I feel like it hasn't delivered on the
promise of what the show was in terms of
how much it was gonna tie into the
Marvel Universe it's felt very insular
it has never really felt as integrated
into the main Marvel Cinematic Universe
as it wanted to now things got better
after the new Captain America came out
and it tied into those events much more
clearly and the show overall got a
little bit better but I've still got a
number of issues with it there's one
character in particular that I really
really really want to see died I
actually think it's important that he
die and that if he doesn't die that when
we get into the second season it's just
gonna be a mess and I'm not gonna say
who it is because I don't want to bring
up spoilers just talking in this I may
do an overall series overview video once
the entire season is finished airing but
I just feel like I need to say a few
words knowing that we're gonna get a
second season look here's the thing guys
what you created initially just it dealt
with all these original characters in
these original stories you have got
decades worth of material and characters
to pull from the comments and you're
just making stuff up I'm not saying you
have to stick to what's in the comics
and what's been done with shield up to
this point but there's so many
characters that can be you can
definitely reinterpret a lot of these
guys I mean there's no reason to stick
to exactly what's on the page just take
some concepts and take some names drop
us a few bones every now and then those
of us who are fans of the comic book and
it can be done without isolating the
mainstream audience it wouldn't take
much a name here or a power there just
something anything it's just it it is so
detached not only from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but from the comic
book source material that it just does
not feel like Marvel it feels very
generic for the most part again it got
better in the later half of the season
and maybe you don't get better with the
second season I'll stick
to find out but right now I'm my
reaction to it getting renewed is kind
of okay well we'll see so what do you
think about this the fact that we're
going to get another season of videos
yield and that we're going to be getting
aging Carter in addition to that if you
don't know this is gonna be period piece
dealing with Captain America's
girlfriend from the first Captain
America movie and sort of the founding
of shield I would be interested to see
things that happen that carry over into
Ages of shield and sort of a call back
way and get just get a little bit of a
tighter continuity going but I'm
actually more excited for that that I am
for a second season of agents of shield
but what about you have you been
following this thing are you excited at
all I mean has any of it tickled you at
all or if he just been like I started
watching because it sounds that awesome
and I just I just didn't stop what just
kind of where I landed I didn't really
perk up until Deathlok showed up and I
was like ooh but even after that I
haven't I feel like they didn't do much
with it oh whatever
I'll come back for a second season and
we'll see if it can pick up steam any
better than it has but drop me a comment
with your thoughts on all this and until
next time this council is adjourned